Harry Potter fans have spent countless
hours mulling over the books in the film
franchise and have devised some pretty
spellbinding theories about the world of
Witchcraft and Wizardry some of which
have even impressed the author herself
let's take a look at some of the most
game-changing of them all muggles
versus wizards why do wizards have to
hide their powers from muggles and if
they are so powerful why aren't they in
charge of the world if history has
taught us anything it's that usually
those with superior firepower and
knowledge win in any matchup however one
redditor had a different idea and it
gives an interesting alternate
explanation wizards and muggles fought a
war sometime in the Middle Ages and the
muggles one in Goblet of Fire it is
revealed that the Ministry of Magic has
to talk to the British prime minister
about bringing a dragon into the country
this implies that the Minister of Magic
reports to the British prime minister
and may require his approval for matters
of this nature
additionally wizards of today appear to
be much less powerful when compared to
ancient wizards like Merlin the Peveril
z' and the founders of Hogwarts
perhaps the muggles were more successful
with their trials and inquisitions than
we were originally led to believe the
real rita skeeter there were a lot of
colorful characters to come and go in
the Harry Potter series but none felt
quite as familiar as a rita skeeter the
intrepid journalist who would stop at
nothing to get her scoop for the Daily
Prophet while her ethics were often
questionable there was something about
her prose that made many fans wonder
whether JK Rowling might have designed
the character to be reminiscent of
herself after all Rowling is also a
writer who also made a detailed
accounting of the non muggle world that
feels very very real some readers at
least one theorist has taken it a step
further and suggested that Rowling
actually is Rita Skeeter in real life
spilling all of these well-documented
details about the Wizarding World to us
no mad types as a means of getting
revenge against those who shunned her
from the other side scratch that last
the secret of core cruxes one process
that never gets fully explained in the
Harry Potter series is how Horcruxes are
made
Lord Voldemort was able to make himself
a bounty of these little life preservers
at some point in his younger years but
he seemed to be the only one who ever
had any backup souls to spare and seem
to be unable or unwilling to create
anymore once our hero started destroying
them so it must have been difficult
Patricia's very dog stuff very dogging
deep JK Rowling herself has been vague
about how they're made though she did
once say that attempts would probably be
deadly for most wizards because it's as
complicated as splitting an atom
according to the Harry Potter world UK
on Twitter Rowling revealed the process
to her editor who allegedly felt like
vomiting after this led 1/r editor to
surmise that cannibalism may be involved
both cannibalism and the creation of
Horcruxes involve stealing a life force
for the absorption of another the theory
seems to have gained some serious
traction and fantastic beasts the crimes
of Grindelwald as it was revealed that
prior to becoming Voldemort pet and
tag-along Horcrux Nagini was actually a
shape-shifting maledictis who had a
female human form before we met her in
the original series
Voldemort may have killed off the piece
of Nagini that was human and swapped in
a piece of his own soul instead in
defense of the Dursleys when Voldemort
tried to kill infant Harry a small piece
of Tom Riddle's soul latched on to
Harry's brain and cozied up in there for
the next 17 years even though Harry was
not a traditional Horcrux we know that
Voldemort presents affected Harry giving
him some of Voldemort's powers and
causing occasional angry and violent
outbursts
what if Harry wasn't the only one
affected by Voldemort presence
Voldemort's Horcruxes were capable of
dramatically changing the personality of
someone exposed to one for extended
periods Harry and Hermione were
frequently snappish and angry while
carrying the locket and normally
happy-go-lucky Ron turned into a raging
jealous mess who abandoned his friends
if a Horcrux can do that to a genial and
good-natured person what might it have
done to the Dursleys who were around
Harry every day for 10 years from the
flashbacks
we know the petunia wasn't exactly a
very nice person as a child and Vernon
was probably no better but it is
interesting to consider that Mae
they're already sour nature's were
further exacerbated by Volta mores evil
influence since Dudley was born the same
year as Harry he's literally lived
almost his entire life around this
Horcrux it almost makes you feel a
little sorry for them
almost Neville's
clumsiness during Neville Longbottom
first flying lesson at Hogwarts he
earned a reputation as clumsy and
perhaps not the brightest student in the
new class of first years there are
plenty of other examples of Neville
being clumsy with magic and spells
during his early years of the school but
that first flying lesson may not have
been Neville's fault at all after
Baltimore's death the Longbottom's were
targeted by Death Eaters and tortured to
insanity which speaks to a definite
animus against the Longbottom's by
Voldemort screw when Professor Quirrell
first tries to kill Harry and Sorcerer's
Stone he does so by bewitching Harry's
broom as he rides it during a Quidditch
match the unnatural movements of Harry's
broom are very similar to what happened
to Neville during his flying lesson what
if that arm breaking incident was
because Quirrell was using the same
charm to exact a little torture on the
Longbottom boy it should also be pointed
out that until it was broken during the
events in order of the Phoenix Neville
was using his father's wand the father
who was driven insane when Neville was
an infant as we all know the wand
chooses the wizard and so some of
Neville's early difficulties with spells
may have been due to him using this
hammy now after Neville gets a new wand
he seems to grow in leaps and bounds in
his confidence and spell abilities self
sorting wizards in Harry Potter and the
Sorcerer's Stone the sorting hat
struggles with where to put Potter after
the boy wizard kept thinking over and
over again
not Slytherin a the sorting hat assured
him that it'd be a good fit for him but
sent him over to Gryffindor instead for
his wishes as a result of that seen some
fans suspect that Harry may not have
been the only one who moved himself to
another house one fan theory suggests
that both ron and hermione were also
sent to Gryffindor rather than houses
they were suited for Hufflepuff and
Ravenclaw respectively because of their
own preferences for Ron the reasoning
behind the choice seems simple enough
all of his family was already in
Gryffindor so he wanted to fit in for
Hermione it may have been a reflection
of her own newfound valor in venturing
into this whole new world alone Centaurs
know all there were two big scenes in
the Harry Potter series that pitted the
titular wizard against his arch nemesis
Baltimore in the Forbidden Forest and
the first may have foreshadowed the last
as one fan theorist points out after his
brush with death as a baby Harry's first
encounter with the Dark Lord took place
in the forest where he was sent to
detention alongside Hermione Ron and
Draco Malfoy with instructions to find
out who was killing off the unicorns
there he found a cloaked figure which
he'd later discovered to be Voldemort
drinking a unicorns blood for Ren's the
Centaur scared the figure away and in
the book was then scolded by his fellow
centaur Bane who warned him we are sworn
not to set ourselves against the heavens
have we not read what is to come and the
movements of the planets the centaurs
didn't go on to spell it out so what we
didn't know at the time was that Harry's
fate was to die at the hands of
Baltimore in that very place the
centaurs pretty much foretold the final
battle before Harry knew the identity of
the cloaked figure that threatened his
life so early on there's something to
think about
protecting Snape the Defense Against the
Dark Arts classroom was a revolving door
for professors at Hogwarts during
Harry's time as a student first there
was Professor Quirrell who carried
Baltimore on the back of his head
then came Gilderoy Lockhart who was a
fraud and lost all his memories due to a
misfired memory charm Remus Lupin also
walked away after he was exposed as a
werewolf then mad-eye moody turned out
to be Barty Crouch jr. in disguise and
Dolores Umbridge got herself dismissed
for insubordination and general
wickedness before Severus Snape was
finally transferred from his position as
potions professor to take over I really
hate children
all the while Snape seemed like the most
obvious choice for the role and some
fans were left to wonder why he didn't
get it until Harry Potter and the
half-blood Prince won there he has that
the Dumbledore never gave him the post
to protect him the idea is that because
he wouldn't let Tom Riddle have the job
years before riddle cursed a position
and assured that everyone who occupied
it would suffer some kind of cruel fate
and serve just one year Dumbledore
refused Snape the job until he made the
unbreakable vow to kill Dumbledore and
thus resigned himself to a horrible year
already
the theory might also explain why Snape
as headmaster installed a Death Eater in
the role next as he was clearly willing
to sabotage the guy on the sly whenever
possible are you incapable of
restraining yourself oh do you take
pride in being an insufferable
know-it-all professor Trelawney was the
real deal she might have caught a lot of
flack for her histrionics but professor
Trelawney was actually on the mark with
her prophecies a lot more often than
people thought for example a reread of
what she predicted in Harry Potter and
the Prisoner of Azkaban has some
theorists believing she predicted
Dumbledore's death long before it
happened because she refused a seat at
Christmas dinner by saying if I joined
the table we shall be thirteen nothing
could be more unlucky never forget that
when 13 dying together the first to rise
will be the first to die with Peter
Pettigrew hiding out in the form of Ron
rat Scabbers there were 13 people at the
table and Dumbledore was the first to
stand meanwhile she might not have been
so wrong in Harry Potter and the Goblet
of Fire when she sensed that Harry was
born in midwinter Harry was a July baby
but what we didn't know at the time was
that a piece of Baltimore was still
embedded in him and Tom Riddle's
birthday just so happened to be December
31st some speculate that her
misinterpretation may have only been due
to the fact that her sense was so strong
that she was picking up on the Dark
Lord's date of birth instead it looks
like Sybill Trelawney shouldn't have
been such a laughingstock after all